hello everyone before I start I want to
say that I'm a Ukrainian and I'm deeply
worried about Russian military
deployment in Crimea I lost my sleep I
lost my appetite I feel like a drug
addict who cannot let go newswire and
Facebook my parents and my children are
in Ukraine and I'm afraid for them I'm
also afraid for my friends which I have
plenty on both sides and they hope that
negotiations and international pressure
will alert the bloodshed because if the
war starts it will be very nasty it will
feel more like a civil war as virtually
every family has a negative on the other
side I thought about changing the topic
of my speech or canceling it all
together but I worked on it for two
months and at the end I decided that I
will not let Putin
I am standing at the roof of a tall
building near the ancient church I hear
a distant noise like you're on doing
wave it is growing and moving in my
direction the ground starts shaking
under my feet boom first crack cut
through the roof boom boom more and more
cracks open up all around I want to run
but my legs are so heavy but I start
moving and when they get to the edge of
the roof I see that the whole town is
taken over by powerful earthquake in the
building just on the other side of the
street from me collapses taking a cloud
of dust into the air I realize I have
nowhere to run nowhere to hide I fever
and wake up
it's four in the morning and i can't
believe i just had one of those dreams
again what are they trying to tell me
what is this powerful force shaking up
my world is it a thread or an
opportunity for me but I was not
analyzing at the time that I'm entering
a midlife crisis and today I want to
tell you this deeply personal story and
share a few lessons Oh 835 I thought I
have everything figured out my life was
close to perfect cool executive job
stable family bright future I was
focused on success and I was very busy
making other people happy my boss my
wife my clients it was not easy but
damned I was good at it my image was
spotted a story of constant progression
so good that even Stanford was unable to
say no to me but deep inside I was far
from being happy I was suffocating I
sought one more project one more
achievement and my happiness will surely
arrive but instead i bought the
earthquake blinked and it was just the
last straw idealised it's all fake I
worked so hard for someone and all I'm
getting is this black I will no longer
play by the rules and instead I turn
towards myself and ask what do you need
to be here
I'm glad you finally asked and through
the dialogue has started those
conversations made me to realize some
uncomfortable truth that I do not really
know myself at the time afraid to know
that with every day I'm getting older
and tomorrow might never come that my
happiness is only my responsibility and
it's not going to happen unless I
embraced not only my light but also my
dark side and so I started changing
coming wait and then prepared for the
board it still fighting occasionally and
falling madly in love with risk and
uncertainty people who knew me were
short my wife wanted psychiatry is to
fix me my voice concluded Anatolia is
lazy but still talented and I remember
my mom cried are you out of your mind
but ironically first time in many years
I was actually fine I felt like an
animal that broke out of its cage and I
gave up safety stability and comfort but
in return i brought freedom presence in
the moment and then ability to improvise
yet this period of my life was
terrifying my perfect life was crumbling
in front of my eyes earthquake his wrath
lessly worked through it turning it into
a pile of debris I quit my dream job I
divorced after 14 years together and I
moved here to the other side of the
globe at times I felt miserable totally
lost and helpless like a newborn baby
and I am extremely grateful to my
relatives for support and for my
teachers of yesht out tantalum trica
analysis for guidance and so today first
time in my life I'm breathing fully the
earthquake has moved on leaving me with
a sound of silence and in this silence I
hear a soft com voice raising from deep
inside of me sometimes I lose it but
sometimes I hear it loud and clear fill
in my every membrane with ecstatic
vibration in those moments I feel an
opening and incredible space in my chest
in those moments I feel goose bumps
running from my feet through my spine to
the back of my head in those moments I
feel my whole body trembles in a single
bit with the universe and sometimes
after those moments I think that maybe
my ex-wife was right and they do need to
see a psychiatrist
now at some point you might experience
tremors to my advice do not go through
this alone seek help there are many
people who get such classes before and
they can help you on this path second do
not try to run away from the earthquake
because you cannot possibly run away
from yourself and remember it's not so
much a threat as an opportunity an
opportunity to find your own voice an
opportunity to reconnect with yourself
on a much deeper level an opportunity
for the awakening and they want to
conclude with the words of one of the
oldest players owners gayatri mantra our
souls mission is to be white house that
will awaken the enlightened being within
others monster